Họng, mấy bố dừng em hiền 2 tháng 6, năm 2018, tại đoạn qua cộng trở thuân phút chương,
xá trình lu, tình hà tính sẻ ra vụ tên hạnh rộ thông dữ xe ao tổ tệ giòn mến thái xe,
xin năm 2012, chú xá đức phọc tình hà tính, đều khiến và xem mấy định gió ông lời hát tế,
xin năm 2019, chú xá trình lu, tình hà tính, đều khiến, chờ theo mẹ là Nở TS, xin năm 2012,
hậu qua, ông tế và mẹ từ phòng cải chỗ. Hình lu tên hạnh đăng được công an tình hà tính điều tra, làm só.
Đều phơi thốc lối ra đường là vi phạm phó bột về ra thông đường bộ,
sự giúp khi cộng hà tình đường bộ trời, vì định làm hẹn phần đường xe chạy,
ở mất an tònh trò phương tệ lưu thông.
Nếu để xe ra hậu qua thị thải về tiếng mạc,
xúc quay và tệ sản của vui thân ra,
xa ra tông tìt theo tính chất nước độ sẽ bị xử và thọc bị chứ chắc nhẹp hiện sự về tội cạnh trở ra thông đường bộ.